you guys see anything okay we'll wait
until dark and then sneak back across
the line around rejoin our unit do you
guys hear something
these Americans proved to be no obstacle
at all search the hotel yeah you've done
well to secure this position I could
bode well for promotion speaking of
which guess who I saw two markets
hesitate
oh oh I don't know Adolf Hitler who
doesn't but you ever see him in person
oh yeah at the Nuremberg rally it was
very inspiration I know it was I was
there everyone was there but up close
it's a whole different thing for
instance it was the weekend and the
cleaners had just started to grow on the
sides of the mustache like this so I
walk up to Hitler casual and comment on
that that's rude I'm in the middle of a
story not interested in a story about
off yoga yeah okay good I'm Ava was
there as well taller than you think or
Hitler's shorter hard to say but anywho
I'm buying some bread
Hitler's buying some bread I must so I'm
assuming you've got a better Hitler
story but no then maybe don't interrupt
yes sir so I give him a salute and he
gives me one of those half Hitler
salutes you know down low very cool
right you know hey here's what you
forget he doesn't say Heil Hitler
funny huh oh wait I think maybe next
time I'll tell him how uninterested you
are in my story jealousy thing no no no
no I didn't meet Hitler to hurt your
feelings
Rosi eat of course so I say to Hitler
I've actually been quite busy hit a
laughs and then says you I mean because
you speak during the cinema the story
has a build but if you keep interrupting
you kills the momentum I'm trying to
tell you that body is moving
that's ridiculous the Americans are all
dead but if it keeps you from
interrupting my awesome Hitler story
I'll prove it to you later
very good sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I never get used to those final death
throes death throes air Muller what is
wrong with you those are not death
throes insubordinate and churlish pity
this is the best part of the story as
Hitler was taking his leave of me he
said well there's no point in getting
word if you're not going to get and at
the same time Hitler said freeze
I said cheese and then Hitler and I both
said jinx both this is like two regular
everyday people's you guys missed the
first part but this is all about Hitler
[Music]